cours des membres de l'équipe
pour l'équipe britannique Clara
Phillips est rentrée à la maison
et elle est actuellement à la deuxième place, il est
rentré à la maison avec le
deuxième meilleur temps que nous avons vu ce
matin
William qui bien sûr est euh champion d'
Europe champion par
équipe plusieurs fois
champion du monde champion par équipe  aussi, euh,
elle est censée être probablement plus petite
que les chevaux, il est génial, il cherche les
géants qui vont très bien, donc euh,
oh
pénalités 12 minutes
122,5 pénalités,
nous avons terminé là pour l'équipe brésilienne,
euh, d'
accord,
mon
william
william fox
a plus de
21 ans
qu'il vient  dans cette
partie du parcours de cross-country
merci
c'est
euh
euh euh
étranger
c'est
l'essentiel
11 minutes
étranger
mon